The Joe Rogan Experience the best thing
is to get in the state we could just be
Doug Stanhope and I go Doug Stan hope
you're on and just push you on and to
get me into that state I have to know
incorrect what time I should not be
shit-faced like that was last night no
no this this don't take 50 milligrams
come on take
175.50 milligrams and then have Joe
Rogan go show starts now let's do
mushrooms let's do mushrooms
I'm scared me too that's the point come
on how long has it been yesterday I did
do uh
I'm doing them all the time all right
small amounts
exactly uh I don't want to even say her
name but yeah Carmen Morales what yeah
she came out she was her name don't say
her name she's a comic don't listen to
me you don't want to say her name don't
say her name
let's call her she would want her name
to be said no no she wasn't dealing
she's giving you drugs yeah don't you've
given me drugs
yeah
don't tell these [ __ ] people can you
black out The Joe Rogan Experience and
just say the experience
when uh I the first time he and I uh did
DMT I was worried I lost him I was
really genuinely oh my goodness we're
gone oh my goodness you had gone my
goodness you had gone to this snoring
thing where I was I was like do I lift
him up so that he doesn't swallow his
[ __ ] tongue I was like oh my God if I
killed Doug if the mancho dies because I
give Doug it was dying by the way that
we knew we were writing the last
monologues ever and that's what [ __ ]
me up I'm sure we've told this story
every time I'm sure on your podcast but
we were at your house writing we know
this is the last of the monologues and
they're [ __ ] just Pap dredge [ __ ]
awful uh what's up it wasn't that bad
but by the end
and we're beaten yeah well there was
some last time you want to smoke DMT
my first time like all right this sucks
and we're just getting through this and
then you you want to smoke DFT and then
I go [ __ ] into alternate realities
and then I come out of it 10 minutes
later saying I remember I I came out of
it just saying oh my goodness oh my
goodness oh my goodness because I've
just learned the [ __ ] you know what
else he said he said you've already seen
this
you said that to me oh you've already
seen this
I swear the picture of [ __ ] Bill
Hicks on your wall winked at me and when
I said that to one with him and the the
lighting the American flag with a
cigarette yeah what you had a lighting
the cigarette with the American flag I
came out of it and I looked and I swear
Bill Hicks [ __ ] winked at me when I
said that to you you went uh [ __ ]
looked at me like cliche
I swear that happened no I'm not even
that big of Bill Hicks fan you were just
you were just insecure because you had
like experienced death and you came back
when we would when I would go outside to
smoke cigarettes from The Writer's room
on the lot after that for a week I
couldn't make direct eye contact with
the giant dumpster-sized electrical
generator because I thought I could make
it blow up with my mind the wiring in my
head was so I've never done it since
people try to drop that off at the merch
Booth we should do it ever again we
should do it tonight [ __ ] no yeah come
on yeah what I'm about to okay when I'm
gonna quit smoking cigarettes you're
better now because of that day
I don't know yeah you are you know why
because you know that that's possible
you didn't know that that was possible
but it's hard to break up okay I'm gonna
write a bit about this that now I know
is dog [ __ ] and means nothing
because I've been through that
experience where you go this is all so
[ __ ] life is so silly but you still
have to make a living by Doug just
Express that you don't have I've been
doing that but I know you have but don't
worry about that it doesn't have to be
dog [ __ ] and silly it's you you don't
think about that think about you
think about if you were like some 24
year old guy working in a [ __ ]
newspaper distributor office you had a
[ __ ] job and you're allowed to
listen to podcasts and you listen to you
talk about your experience don't worry
about like your own [ __ ] weirdness in
in handling it worry about what it is
what it is is like you died and came
back like you really felt like you died
and came back when you came back I
didn't feel like I died you said to me
you said to me
here's say your honor this is what you
said you said life eats life he said
life just eats life life eats life life
eats life wow this is what you said when
you were coming out you were like life
just eats life life just he's like it
just keeps going it keeps going life
Heats life life eats life I'm just
trying to hang on life eats life life
eats life he's like you already been
there you've already been here you've
already been here ultimately no like you
took you took me to this place you
already been there I'll never forget
that because I thought you were gonna
die and I was like God damn it nobody's
ever died from this [ __ ] like if Doug's
the first guy to die I'm like he's like
maybe I like overestimate the RPMs that
his [ __ ] engine handle and redlined
but you you got through it and that was
the thing you kept saying life eats Life
Life Is Life Life Is Life but but the
the the
dichotomy of having to go from that
Supernatural experience in 10 minutes
and then go back to oh wait now we
really have to try it finishing up these
dumb monologues yeah but that's okay too
yeah that's okay too because that's a
unique challenge that's like there's
some weird thing we're doing like what
are we doing